[Music]
that's Canada what's up gamers welcome
to Canada vlog it's my first time in
Canada they prepared for us
[Laughter]
we got birthday truffle oh I can't say
that I'll get to monetize your lame joke
I'm such a dad nap no I'm not wait I
shouldn't even joke about that yeah I
can it's really cool so far
we haven't really see much but I really
like it everyone's super friendly we got
a couple things to do here tomorrow
we're doing a pop-up shop for Sookie
which should be really fun we're going
to get some this is supposed to be so
spicy extremely spicy so they give you
milk
it's not even Robin Timmy that
yeah we just had amazing food now we're
gonna walk to shopping mall it's really
weird being here I haven't been in a big
city in a very long time
well we've been in Tokyo but this is so
different I don't know it's still having
an actual big city that makes no sense
I'm a Boomer promise' forbids me to PI
why are they so big that's it that's so
big oh yeah it's a Google office
damn it to ring in st. Cyprian pi
it's like seven or something eight we're
still gonna go back and say because I'm
so tired
epic vlog see you tomorrow and epic time
let's go okay oh god my eggs extra gonna
die oh my god oh no I didn't mean to
leave it epic view good morning well
that's pretty cool actually you see the
tire today what are we doing today we're
doing the pom-pom shop that's why I'm
wearing Suki very epic we're gonna meet
some of you guys we're gonna sell some
clothes check out suki da market guess
who's the dumbass who forgot to bring
his glasses and contact lenses
my vision is pretty bad I'm not gonna
lie like I can't see very far this up
close is fine so I'll just blog like
this and it'll be okay alright here we
are
it looks amazing look at this
beautiful so cool I kind of want to nab
one of the shirts we had people waiting
outside apparently since 5:00 a.m. but
then we came and they were just like so
polite
okay so this is our little
meet-and-greet area and we got people
waiting out there they don't see us is
your first meeting green how does it
feel
[Music]
so cool we just rent it was super nice I
think so cool everyone was super nice I
gotta say no nine-year-olds no actual
nine year olds it was very low-key like
we didn't tweet or post about it yeah so
you know up to hardcore torrent tons
were the ones that were there oh wow
your mom's pizza I'm are yeah right
thing I didn't know she working someone
had too much to drink
so did this guy you get that artsy shot
oh that's cool actually I got a great
shine that was Kensington Market hope
you guys enjoyed it down here is like
Chinatown I think we found it a chair to
fit me cuz I have long legs you're
merging want to get some flip-flops just
a couple
oh my god what is this you don't like it
how much is look what you got is that
freshly Maine damn this is an boomer
[ __ ] right here attitude I think I found
it I got together this one please
alright we've been out a couple hours
still raining
[Music]
there's donating money count if you
don't tell people about it
I finally got it to work the team trees
donation epic donate to team trees what
team are you want in trees happy
Halloween so this will be my first time
driving in Toronto I don't know what to
expect I mean I driven in LA I feel like
it should be fine but it's been a while
and my brain is not very big you know we
had the option to fly there it's like a
15-minute fly but I like unlike all
these fake-ass billionaires that's like
environment is so important and then
they fly in jet maybe it's worse to
drive out or not I am driving so sloth
I'm sweating I think the best day ever
to try
[Music]
turn left in 150 meters onto fader
Street where is everyone
it's somewhere that is Wow both white
gold and kostina
coal we made it to Niagara Falls it's us
and one other guy excuse me excuse me
whoo did they hiss that mean I think
that was hissing at me
there it is so that's where we're going
later that looked terrifying
I was worried that you wouldn't see it
but you also kind of can't but I think
that goes for any day damn
[Music]
I guess send it's Halloween I thought
there would be all over people
oh my god my [ __ ] are you ready or why
there's no one here that's great here we
are we're going to the first one and
then we're going to that one anything
the soaked inning is beginning
[Music]
people said you will get soaked but yeah
they weren't like I can't keep my eyes
open
or require that was awesome
people said Niagara was a little bit
like a mini Las Vegas
and we didn't really know what they
might this is so touristy I did not
expect this I guess we're going here
[Music]
this place is so weird what is happening
they said if thunder comes out
[Music]
my mom we're doing the haunted house
it's Halloween we want to do the chicken
exit Marcia right we're powering through
yeah the floor tilted oh my god that was
good that was good
oh the caskets Oh God we should probably
do something about that will tell the
guy I want it's fine I just walked into
this is way scarier than I thought that
was actually scary oh no one keeps going
oh hey hey oh it's us hey hey
you didn't get hey hey oh that means
we're gonna die we didn't yes
that was scary I think as it was only
you and me it was like way scarier but
yeah we're weekly that's it from us for
anger falls very epic would rate it nah
[Music]
look at that big boy that's a big boy
welcome to day 3 of Toronto vlog today
we're visiting the aquarium and the
tower very epic it's very cold today as
well very cold in case anyone else now
you know it's very cold Hey look I found
your mom bra look at this dude
it's got a bigger nose than me oh my god
that's terrifying
oh dude he's got snore snow where I was
I you know what do you want to say it's
a camera dude those lame stuff Loki
would make out oh wait we can't see you
man I just see sign here I don't see
anything else
that's crazy look how fluffy burn a
treadmill
oh the spooky
that is one big-ass fish whoa holy
smokes so big big mystery it's a lot of
kids here if you don't watch out then I
become the face might say I finally
found her puffer fish where are they is
it you okay ma'am oh my god it looks so
that's nice yeah hey guys what's up hey
what's up girl
where's the ask found it
so sexy damn go okay guys that was
awesome
but now we're doing the tower broth and
hotdogs that someone Canada smells like
according to Myers Ian yeah we are at
the top
Wow hey hey whoa wow that is very tom
the zoom on this lens da come on
very cool
I like it a lot I think of horror Hotel
is there somewhere if you can see steam
coming
we found our hotel it's like there
[Music]
power I will rate it hmm
it's an eight we're going to a
restaurant now this is supposed to be
really good it's called quanta what are
you doing max is trying to buy Shane
Dawson's pallet
I'm feeling very boomer right now so
these are all the boxes for Sookie I
never seen so much courage yeah
[Music]
okay it's the next day so we are flying
in a couple hours Meyer says editing
this log right now Thank You Meyers
again Canada was really cool I really
like Toronto it's very pretty
people are very nice and it was very
exciting to see Sookie pop-up shop
seeing your clothes in a store for the
first time thanks to everyone who came
to to the shop and support it I think
it's really cool I would like to do more
stuff like this and thanks to everyone
working on Sookie to making that happen
I think it's super fun and I hope you
enjoyed this vine that's it bye bye hey
go hey heeey finger-touch okay